many Americans rely on online reviews to
choose a business or a service 82
percent of adults say they read online
reviews at least some of the time
that's according to a Pew Research
Center study but posting a review could
put you at risk of being sued CTM
consumer investigative correspondent
andrew warner is here with details on
that ana what do people need to know a
lot of people use this service right and
gale posting reviews is second nature
for many people nowadays and they have a
bad experience with a business up goes
the review to share with others but for
one man in florida what he thought was a
simple review turned into a year-long
battle in court I never thought I'd be
sued over anything i right I'd there's
no reason to say anything but the truth
but Thomas Loyd of DeLand Florida says
telling the truth got him in trouble his
ordeal began when his ten year old
poodle Rembrandt suddenly fell ill last
year lloyd rushed him to nearby DeLand
Animal Hospital where he says he was
told the dog needed immediate surgery
for what was probably a ruptured spleen
I said you're gonna do this right now
and he said yeah but six hours later he
says the clinic told him to come pick
Rembrandt up that they'd been unable to
find a surgeon he took the dog to a
second clinic but says he was told it
was too late
Rembrandt would need to be euthanized it
isn't like there's a closure he deserved
a chance they didn't give him a chance
if he had died on the operating table I
would have understood
afterwards he posted a review on Yelp
writing the staff had wasted
six hours of Rembrandt's life and
destroyed whatever chance he may have
had to live our Rembrandt deserved a
better last day weeks later DeLand
Animal Hospital and veterinarian Thomas
MacPhail sued him for defamation
alleging Lloyd's statements were false
and published maliciously and recklessly
I'm finding out that isn't always cheap
to to give an honest review because if
the other person has money they they can
drive you in the ground when we spoke
with him in May Lord Oh $26,000 in legal
more than his yearly Social Security
income and he's not the only person
who's been sued last year a New York
woman was sued by her doctor for
$1,000,000 for posting negative online
reviews a man in Kansas was sued over a
3-star TripAdvisor review of a theme
park and a South Carolina woman was sued
by a restaurant
she claimed refused to honor a coupon
we're seeing a rise in individuals being
sued for speaking out online
'even Mascagni works for the public
participation project and says many
lawsuits are designed simply to
intimidate they're called slap lawsuits
for strategic lawsuit against public
participation a slap filer doesn't go to
court to seek justice they are just
trying to silence or harass or
intimidate a critic of theirs some
states have laws against slap lawsuits
but there's no federal anti slap statute
earlier this year the FTC began cracking
down on businesses that put gag clauses
in their consumer contracts in violation
of the consumer review Fairness Act
FTC's Carl settle Meyer why is it
important enough that the government
feels like hey we need to step in
sometimes well the online review medium
has really exploded over the past you
know decade or so and people's reliance
on an ability to learn from online
reviews has really grown in proportion
to that you know people have stories to
tell and they're not able to to get them
out because they feel like they're you
know gonna be gonna be threatened Thomas
Lloyd's stuck to his guns and
countersuit earlier this year two former
veterinarians from DeLand gave sworn
affidavits saying even though they
lacked experience doing the emergency
surgery Lloyd's dog needed veterinarian
MacPhail had declined to do the surgery
and instead left for vacation after the
animal hospital's attorneys learned of
our interview with Lloyd the case was
quickly settled they shouldn't be able
to try to financially break somebody
just because they don't like what you
say DeLand Animal Hospital is now under
new ownership the new owners told us the
lawsuit was filed prior to them taking
over veterinarian MacPhail is no longer
working at the Haas
little he did not respond to our
repeated requests for comment for this
story oh I so feel for mr. Lloyd you can
still see his pain and he's just really
speaking from what happened in his own
experience he didn't strike me as a
malicious man so what can you put in an
online review you can't say anything
negative yeah well so here's the thing
what they'll tell you is stick to your
own experience don't generalize and say
you know this pharmacy is the worst in
history and it does this to all these
people stick to your own experience in
that what he did though well and yes and
here and that's the point Galen even if
you do do that that's not that doesn't
mean that somebody can't sue you they
can sue you if they want to sue you
there's an opinion protect it if you say
this is the worst pharmacy I've ever
been to but but if somebody Sue's you
you're gonna have to go to court and say
it is my opinion and it is protected
potentially now in some states there are
these laws right anti slap laws but the
protections vary across the country
there's no federal statute to prevent
these types of lawsuits so depending on
your state you know might not hurt it's
it gets into the weeds but maybe you can
go read about your own states wow I
never thought I'd be saying that but you
know let the negative online reviewers
have their day you may win but you end
up spending a lot in legal fees
right right potentially yeah and I thank
you very much